ايقافات ستتلوها اخرى هكذا ينطلق القضاء
التونسي في التعامل مع متهمين بالاعتداء
على امن الدوله قيادات محسوبه على النهضه
من سياسيين وامنيين ورجال اعمال وقضاه
معزولين هم الان رهن الايقاف والسجن في
انتظار استكمال مسار الاصلاح بعد
الاجراءات الاستثنائيه هكذا يتحدث الشارع
التونسي المشغول بهموم قوت يومه من الندور
تلقى الازمات وراء الازمات راهم اللي هم
كانهم الدوله مويزيه معناها مش معناها
المسؤولين قاعدين يحكموا هم قائمين بدور
الدوله الموازيه الايقافات متاخره برشا
طريقه ايقافات هي اللي متشرفش الشعب
التونسي ومتشرفش الثوره التونسيه
عبر التاريخ يؤكد الرئيس سعيد في رد على
منتقديه من الداخل والخارج ان مطلب
المحاسبه الشعبيه وان كل الاجراءات
قانونيه محترمه سياده الدوله واحده كما
يقول
لسنا تحت الاستعمار او الحمايه او
الانتداب نحن دوله مستقله
ذات سياده
الا ان مساله سياده الدوله تثار عند
المتابعين بين عمل اجهزتها للحفاظ على
استمرار الدوله او العوده الى مربع
الارتهان للخارج او الدخول الى منطقه
الفوضى
نتحدث عن ايقافات اليوم يجب ان نتجاوز
مساله مجرد المناوشات السياسيه طبيعه
الاسماء التي اوقفت في القضيه تحيل الى
قضيه امن دوله بامتياز بمعنى هناك مخطط
لاسقاط السلطه القائمه لم يتوانى القائمون
به على التصحيح به علنا يعني هناك من قال
لرئيس الجمهوريه لديك مهله للخروج الامن
هناك من استنجد بالاجهزه
لاسقاط الدوله
ورغم الجدل المسار اليوم حول الايقافات
الاخيره الا ان جل المتابعين يؤكدون انها
محطه اخرى على درب تعديل البوصله واستكمال
الخيار الاصلاحيه والاجراءات الاستثنائيه
في البلاد وا القوس منظومه الاخوان
والفساد وليد عبد الله العربيه تونس